alright guys for ages people have been
asking me Greg can you have a rating
system actually on your videos Greg I
cannot actually understand how you feel
about a film despite you talking about
it for on average ten plus minutes
without you giving a defined rating
system where's your awesome tacular
where's your a plus where's your five
out of ten schmoes here it is people get
ready for the ultimate rating system BAM
photo ignore the sirens in the
background so I'd appreciate that let me
guide you through it if a film is close
to perfect or is practically perfect I
call it a masterpiece that's one rating
right there if it's not exactly a
masterpiece but it's still awesome might
call it awesome but Jeremy Johnson saw
spectacular so I call it fantastic or
amazing still though fantastic or
amazing there's still one below that
words great and if a film is just you
know average better than okay better
than fine better than decent it's good
but if it's not good it might be okay
finder decent then sometimes the film
was just bad horrible terrible you know
these means you you better know this is
the best really taken like but it's just
good fair poor great and then a couple
major no it's horrible terrible at the
bottom bad it's not exactly horrible or
terrible what's bad options have options
okay fine or decent that's something I
would do good great fantastic or amazing
or a masterpiece I just don't I can't
quite think of a film that's great but
it's not a fantastic or amazing but it's
too nuanced to the point that now
that people get confused what if i use
amazing in a different way than youtube
I'm coining these words now patented
okay how about it's a good time if
you're high this is what we are
temporarily sticking with because I
believe in the new rating system